listo entonces mientras tanto
voy a abrir unas cosillas para sus asistencias discutidas y listo
voy a inicializar su n8 en n, vamos a hacer unas cosillas más, un poquito más complejas pero
va a alcanzar el tiempo, esperemos que el cansa así que vemos rotito
mientras voy sacando asistencias vemos rotito
yo
ya empezamos entonces
ahorita os voy a comentar algo específico perdón rotito
ya bueno vean habilitando su n8 en n de mí está tardando bastante así que
mientras tanto bueno ya está casi
mientras tanto vamos a hacer unos ejercicios para las demás dos clases que vamos a tener
demos rotito a ver, vamos a permitir a alguien más personas
ya habilitaremos y ahorita lo entendemos en cuenta
ya listo ya se habilitó el mío
ya veremos un nuevo workflow directamente colóquenlo en este caso como título que lo hace n 12 y van a
colocar su pavición listo ya ese ese nombrecito le van a dar ahora voy a mientras tanto
sacar la parte ahora voy a hacer lo siguiente van a mirar una carpeta una carpeta que ustedes
tengan donde están tras bajando sus proyectos netamente ahí voy a ir medio escritorio a ver
listo me voy a ir a lo que es esto
me voy a crear una carpeta no voy a colocar proyectos
proyectos ahí me voy a crear y vamos a empezar a hacer algunos puntos ya una vez que estén
ahí adentro se van a entrar y voy a hacer clic derecho demos rotito voy a admitir a alguien más
ya una vez que han creado esa carpetita vuelvo a repetirlos crean una carpetita muy aparte
donde están trabajando netamente con n 8 n pongan el nombre que ustedes deseen no no es
necesariamente que pongan lo mismo que estoy colocando así que en ese sentido no hay problema
luego clic derecho van a abrir terminal y directamente colocan
cout espacio punto y se los va a habilitar directamente lo que habíamos visto anteriormente
no la parte de su vez visor este cout así que la mía ya se me ha habilitado le voy a mostrar
y tal de otra pantalla pero ya está ya lo que vamos a hacer lo siguiente voy a tratar de codificarlos
rápidamente tratan de seguirme voy a codificar a mano luego vamos a meter inteligencia artificial
pero por qué lo voy a hacer a mano porque es necesario un cachito entender porque estamos
trabajando y hay que entender el código un poquito sé que no sé qué es que no estamos en una clase
de programación pero lo más adecuado y lo más necesario se va a tratar de especificar como lo
vamos a trabajar ya en para esta parte voy a hacer lo siguiente ya vienen extensiones en
extensiones aquí a día que lado dice van a colocar en este caso html html venían lo que
tienen instalado ustedes por defecto el boilerplate o también pueden trabajar con el html ss es mejor
ya esto pueden instalarse vuelvas a repetirles es html ss su port y instala el dicen transport
visión estall y listo esto les va a crear automáticamente algunos puntos ahora que más
necesitan a ver voy a venir acá y voy a colocar ccs ccs y vamos a instalarnos un pic sería a lo pics
y la serie finicia ahora se entra acá a ver si me conviene de un rotito
y ya les va a servir este instala en ccs peck o pic perdón
listo esos dos ya voy a admitir algunas personas más listo ya esos dos vienen instalándose que
más necesitarían a ver modus es bueno pero vamos a ver si se ha actualizado
y el otro seis es una vigilan también les va a servir y a los snippets este también es interesante y
es necesario ya por ejemplo este automáticamente me crea el código ya predefinido ya esta parte
les va a ayudar bastante instalense también este html ss ss y a bespear los snippets y lo instalan ya
y trust y polícia listo ya quiero que me sigan todo lo que voy a hacer porque eso se va a hacer
para la siguiente y la siguiente clase ya de un roto ahora sí empezaremos entonces voy a hacer
esto y voy a crearme dos archivos ya un index punta html
pero voy a crearme un style style es punto ccs listo y a ojo esto lo pueden hacer con ella
ya pero a modo que ustedes tengan en cuenta que voy a trabajar un poquito con más código
vamos a tener en cuenta eso de un rato aquí en este fuera
y entonces
y hasta 10 vamos a subir de ahí
y de un rato y así la cierra
y
listo ya entonces una vez que tienen eso vamos a tratar de trabajar con ese aspecto ya entonces
si sean y hay instalados a ambos otros tres extensivos que les han enviado directamente aquí
pueden colocar html ya y les va a aparecer esto pueden trabajar con el cinco colo de más digamos
apretó ese se va a crear eso ahora lo traremos a ver html igual voy a colocar html a ver sin
vamos a ver qué me da ya me auto genera el código el html cinco ya ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es trabajar en un tipo de proyecto ya va a ser corto pero va a ser algo más aplicativo por
ejemplo quiero colocar un catálogo de zapatos mi tienda no creo que la tienda mejor la tienda digamos
que es el zapato ya en este caso voy a colocar un script y dentro de ese script van a hacer
los siguientes de indica pero dentro de script así van a colocar script y vamos a hacer algo
así listo ya todavía no vamos a colocar nada voy a colocar un en este caso una URL que ahorita
lo vamos a colocar y luego de esto voy a linkarme ya con el mi estilos lo voy a dar de estilos es
decir este html trabaja con para que se vuelva bonito tenemos que jalar el estilo ya estilos
en este caso para que nosotros podamos conectarnos a los estilos voy a colocar en este caso link
ya link luego van a colocar rel y dos puntos van a colocar ahí en este caso estilos y
les aparece automáticamente ya esto van a colocar dentro de la
de los comillas dobles listo luego href y este hecho rep les va a direccionar directamente
a este archivo al estilos si los estilos está en otro lado también pueden colocar esto lo voy a
quitar miren lo veis a lo siguiente digamos que voy a ener voy a colocar ccs ya y ahí lo voy a jalar
este porque siempre es bueno trabajar los sus proyectos ordenadamente ya hay en informática
que son desarrolladoras ya tienen base de esto y eso se llama estructura ya y en base de estructuras
nosotros dijimos de diferentes tipos de frames ya esto lo voy a linker ahí para linkarme y voy a
colocar ccs barra y me voy a linker ahí y me aparece automáticamente si se dan cuenta ya nada más
ahora acá por ejemplo puedo crear la parte del body a ver voy a colocar a esto más pueden
instalarse siguen decen extensiones van aquí van a colocar laiz
está los extender acá live server instalance mints voy admitir algunas personas
de un ratón listo ya entonces es el live server que están viendo ahí me hace para que
automáticamente se abra con con una tecla ya ahorita os me indica cómo van a estar abriendo
desde carpeta y demás y entonces ahorita lo que yo necesito es de su tarea no para hoy sino
para la siguiente semana es que sí o sí ustedes tengan en cuenta que tienen que ir a trabajar
en sus proyectos ya entonces como ya le hemos le estoy aquí colocando un script que me va a
redireccionar a una API ahorita os veo mucha cual luego estoy colocándome un link para darme
algún estilo que se vuelva algo bonito y atrae entre el sistema y en base eso voy a trabajar
ya ahora dentro del body el body para mí es el cuerpo del de la aplicación del sistema del
negocio etcétera voy a colocar el título y el título siempre van a colocar el h1 aquí luego
lo pueden mejorar la cuestión que ahorita los estoy enseñando los que acaban de entrar
algo estructurado ya catálogo de zapatos
zapatos listo dentro de ahí puedo colocar en este caso un buscador o sea quiero buscar cuál es mi
catálogo por ahí tengo 20 40 productos no sé es para llevar a colocar input en este caso voy a
hacer así y hay di buscar esa es la como la clave secreta de los para llamar la tiempo
por eso su id ya el placeholder generalmente lo que aparece por ejemplo cuando ustedes
entren a su usuario y contra señales piden aquí ingresa usuario dicen hay unas letritas por
debajo eso para mí es el placeholder ya y que voy a colocar buscar zapatos
listo entonces lo cierran esto y abraremos la prueba está ahí
ya como yo los he hecho que se ven a instalar voy a apretar lo siguiente contra chifpe
y van a escribir live server ahí está y ven parecido live server open with live server hacen
click y automáticamente se les va a abrir una ventana
y esa ventana está acá y hace me abierto
ahí está buscamos zapatos no sé ya ahora le podemos dar a estos estilos si se puede dar
estilos como lo pueden dar porque lo hemos linkeado anteriormente los estilos y a esos estilos pueden
trabajar de manera sincrona sincrona y demás pero se va a depender mucho de ustedes y cómo van
a trabajar el futuro ya ahora antes de comenzar esta parte vamos a irnos a lo que realmente a
mi me interesa que es la parte de sistematización pero ya tenemos esto ahora fijarse lo que voy a hacer
acá arriba dice opening agents ya pueden al crocara irse les va a abrir esto
y una gente ya que se copa y lo de ellos los más el cloud bueno este es este es obviamente el que
es paga y lo demás ya pero en este caso digamos me voy a salir un rato llevó a ser los siguientes
de los latidos chicos ahí pueden agregarlo y digamos y pueden agregar su sistema pero hay otra manera
ya pueden abrir a capa en integrator vamos a ser los siguientes todavía no voy a
más avanzar con ustedes voy a abrirme alguna inteligencia artificial que no sea tan complicada y
barata y a ver un open chat esto es el que viene por defecto no van a que decir la cam a mi index
dale estilos no se es una pregunta básica
ya ahí va a evaluar y demás y esperen suba msp se los activar y va a generar hacerlo su
sistema ya no es necesario ingresar a chp y generar nuestros cosas
copero el y procesar listo
y
ahora esta parte esto no puede no viernes que vaya craneando
listo y nada más esperamos un coche
ahí esperamos
y eso los voy esperando ustedes y var
para que vayan ya trabajando bueno paralelamente comentarles no que
en este caso chicos vamos a pasar quizás y en un aria y media o sino una hora y cuarto una hora
porque la embajada dice así que tenemos que extender los normas los unos que dar esas clases
y lo voy a terminar el temayo dentro de un día una clase más
ya la siguiente y la siguiente ya estaría terminando totalmente así que
vamos a extenderlo un poquito para que no les diga nada y bueno se cumpla todo el aspecto
no ahorita les voy a comentar esa parte bueno ya me he creado no está creando un montón de cosas
ahí ahí le van a entender qué van a hacer las partes rojas cómo lo van a aceptar por ejemplo aquí
me he creado dos cabezas ahorita vamos a eliminarlo pero que me termine de de crear y de
listo marcos pas completado está añadiendo y demás esto se llama vaip coding
listo esto hundo y esto vamos a colocarlo hundo también listo
y hasta a ver eso lo voy a guardar para guardarlo van a colocar aquí directamente
y listo y esto también controles y ahora si se dan cuenta la esto que abierto
o en este caso ahora dale los estilos necesarios por ejemplo acá hace rato me lo ha hecho pero
aquí está mis estilos ahorita lo vamos a limpiar a fíjense cómo acá por ejemplo acá cómo se
genera los estilos digamos acá voy a colocar el clas las para llamar sus tíos aquí pueden dar
la calma un montón de cosas las digamos no sé body que tenga este estilo este estilo pueden
crear el mismo estilo ahí adentro pero lo malo que cuando crean el código es bien feo o sea se va
extendiendo y demás ya pueden dar digamos puedo incluso colocar esto en cada uno o jalar estos cada
uno de estos tiene sus propios estilos se dan cuenta voy acercándome y me da diferentes
tipos de aspectos ya y obviamente acá se les va a mejorar por ejemplo en body miran ha mejorado
algo y todos un color int un color medio fondo hay y puedo darle más que todo la parte de
procesos a ver lo voy a decir otro mira a mi index dale aplicale los estilos aplicale
los estilos y añade más de un catálogo
un catálogo de 25 no mucho más de 10
tipos de zapatos
listo entonces se les va a crear ya mientras tanto hasta que vea creando vamos a lo siguiente
ya vamos a venir acá yo voy a empezar de cero con usted porque aquí ya tengo
proyectos llenos que voy a abrir abranse un su Google muy aparte y voy a hacer lo siguiente
digamos es nuevo así que listo van a colocar acá en este caso su pavé
ya aquí dice su pavé de pros de volar mi platform en senai
ahora se van a linkar ya van a colocar sin
ya como este creo que no tiene no me recuerdo se tenía
así no tengo aquí dice continuar con tu github o con tu CEO en este caso mi github y está
regado la tendría que crear mucho github con ustedes a ver a ver ustedes pueden decir no se hace
con esto o con su email ya a ver no voy a acordar mi email de esta cosa
no voy a hacer la prueba nunca hecho con con email siempre lo que hay que dar mi github
ustedes también tienen github igual así que si no pueden que lo consigue
ya va a bien ventar o a ver a ver que me recuerdo
y ojalá que me sopas
sin github me está diciendo o a ver si vemos que me sopa
y en la incredencia ya vamos a entrar directamente con el github y a esto parte ya se tiene ya si
no tienen esta parte van a entrar acá y aquí dice que ha hecho en sin constant ahí
entran y directamente aquí se van a crear ya sin y aquí pueden entrar con su propio
cuenta ya en este caso es mi nuevo esto
ya está ahí vayan creándose la cuenta ustedes ya ya yo no quiero tu cuenta porque
siempre para github no trabaja solamente con una máxima dos cuentas porque ahí está tu
tus skills en el espalharse ya esa parte les espera hasta ahí mientras tanto ya me ha creado esta cosa
ya voy a colocar que que y voy a eliminar la parte superior que que le había creado anteriormente
ya a ver qué me ha hecho que me ha creado me ha creado a ver vamos a hacer la prueba voy a ver
dónde estaba mi actualización de la observer ahí está
algo está bien solamente tendría que jalar quizás
imágenes no para jalar imágenes pueden crecer acá y que derecho y en vez de listo las imágenes
ya pueden jalar por ejemplo ahorita lo está linkeando con qué se llama links orales ya
supuestamente están en la web cosas las imágenes si vengo acá voy a colocar a ver
imágenes de zapatos
entro ahí voy a venir así me voy a venir acá
voy a hacer acá que derecho aquí me dice copiar dirección de la imagen algo clica y lo copio
luego me voy a ir a mí acá y en vez de esto que estaba viéndolo voy a esto un poquito
hacerlo aquí lo voy a copiar ahí vamos a ver si se modifica controla y se para guardarlo y
automáticamente quizás ya ven ya está el zapatito ya veamos una más para que tengan otro ejemplo
digamos tengo unos tenis ya los tenis éste se parece más de catálogo y así que algo
clic de derecho ya saben copiamos dirección de la imagen vengo directamente acá y lo voy a copiar
este ya algunos me dan de procreate sus datos pues que no me salen algunos ya controlese y
automáticamente se va a actualizar esto no ya está ven y así van armando sus catálogos de sus
proyectos nada más qué es lo que voy a hacer yo bueno era que lo ponga al principio para que se
vuelva algo bonito así que espero en tanto ahí voy a colocar las dos imágenes más para que
tenga un catálogo bastante aplicativo a ver de un rato pueden trabajar con imágenes o en este
caso también pueden descargar las imágenes y directamente crearse ahí y poner sus datos no hay
problema ya ahí digamos ya listo unito más
ya unos
y acá estos pares
digamos es
y así vean creando seguridad pero en base pueden repetirlo pueden hacer en base su proyecto no hay
problema y uno más voy a colocar acá porque quiero ponerlo en producción nuestros bello señores
aporte no copió creo perdón
ahora sí
listo controlesa ya debería de estar ya está ahí podemos buscar en este caso clasica
etcétera eso lo vamos a modificar y mejorarlo ahora voy a irme acá a su pavéis no su pavéis
entra con el otro ustedes para que no tengan problemas y hacen y es alinqueado no es porque
solamente es aceptar lo que estábamos haciendo acá siguiente siguiente siguiente y listo y esto no
voy a entrar por acá voy a entrar por por mi cuenta que ya tengo ustedes se pueden crearse y la nueva
ya una vez que tengan eso voy a venir acá voy a colocar en este caso su pavéis
ya moví al inquear directamente
y voy a venir acá y voy a hacer en este caso mi guitz
ya esperemos ahí
está muy lento o es mi internet no sé
listo ahí una vez que ingresen a su hit hasta los espero
ya entonces acá por ejemplo ahí sus polas que van a colocar y acá directamente voy a crear
bien acá colocan un repositorio y van a ser lo siguiente
ya vuelvo a repetir bien en a su acá tener acá
directamente bien a esta cosita que dice más hacen clic y van a colocar nuevos repositorios
dentro del nuevo repositorio van a colocar aquí su proyecto en este caso es para mi zapatería
no se le pueden colocar algo más no es bueno que lo colocó solamente así zapatería zapatón
listo descripción ejemplo de n8n aplicativo a negocios yo siempre lo colocó así eliminar
con solamente algo pero si entonces una vez que tengan ese caso lo creo
ya a él es va a aparecer ahora van a hacer lo siguiente bien acá esta carpetita se van a
recordar donde estaba voy a abrir en este caso mi mi carpetita donde estaba ese proyecto y voy a
hacer lo siguiente miren lo que voy a hacer ahí clic derecho vengo aquí a abrir terminar
me va a aparecer esto voy un poquito minimizar
ya ahí ahora fíjense acá todos estos puntos que ven acá tienen que seguir
ya ahora pueden instalar seguir y a cómo se puede instalar y si es que no se conoce
instalar y aquí está y insta esto se puede instalar
bien aquí 11 ssm punto com vienen y eligen con el su sistema operativo en mi caso es windows
luego lo bajan para 64 para 64 y no más yo así que lo descargan clic aquí se doblan y se
van a lo van a en este caso instalar ya pueden hacer eso ahora y van a seguir todos estos pasos
y ahí a yo voy a venir acá
ahí no se coge abierto este que es ya este
porque era sino me recuerdo siempre tenéis seguros de que carpet están subiendo
capaz no más suben por no fijarse la ruta capaz suben sus hots personales sus chats
sus cosas netamente familiares cosas íntimas y si se equivocan esa parte ya les van a clonar
y a veces esa cosa parte siempre tienen que tener cuidado porque en la anécdota mi mis
alumnos por ejemplo a la rápida porque representan sus trabajos no saben colocar fotos de sus
viajes sus cuenzo bancarias no sé que siempre hacía pero eso se está viendo ya pues tengan cuidado
que están subiendo ya una vez que ven eso van a ir acá ya de coca y comit díganme perdón
esto estoy repitiendo todo lo que está ahí ya ahí dice le odio antes de esto voy a copiarme esto
esta parcito eso o todo esto me voy a copiar y a lo demás puedo seguir escribiendo porque
esta es su ruta de ustedes entonces es que estaba no ya es bien ahí ahora voy a colocar
en el marito y en el becker que es a
ese ritm y no lo van a añadir ustedes está aquí segundo no porque su sistema no es frame
no es un framework ni tiene los procesos de instalación y nada más así que directamente
aquí comit se van a ir y aquí comit y aquí van a colocar no sé lo que ustedes quieran pero yo lo
coloco siempre first first comit o primer comit o uno se depende de cómo yo voy a hacer con ustedes
ya first comit listo su primer comidas ya y ya en este caso me está diciendo que esto se
hay que subir ya hay una carpeta esa y eso es lo que tenemos ahora que hemos creado eso le van a
colocar gritte y branch tal cual como está ya y ahora van a colocar lo que se ha encompañado
contra el be porque su ruta y listo ahora voy a colocar push get push origen me listo y
hasta y ya a pesar que me de fe te puedes yo voy a ver que te puede ir ayer a otro vamos a modificar
ya hasta y les voy esperando
y una vez que si es que se les dificulta esto porque veces y para un nivel de mi power share
a veces es un lío yo lo hago para esconder como en prompt y es lo mismo ya pero es para dar guíales
más o menos como lo van a hacer ya hasta y más o menos ya lo van a tener ahora si nos pueden hacer
esto voy a ver ahora mi cmed lo que vamos a hacer y los voy a repetir los pasos y demás
pero voy a ser rápido acá para que no tengamos ahora cómo pueden hacer digamos que no se olviden
cómo entrar digamos y no están entrando ahí directamente se pueden hacer así copian esto su
ruta luego van a copiar cd listo y ahí van a ingresar y ahí van a coger y y demás
y hay colocan y comit y listo y ahí van copiando todo esto y comit lo pegan ahí
ya si no quieren escribir y demás
y
y ya y es brán lo copian y lo pegan y así sucesivamente ya luego ya lo pueden hacer desde
consola o sea consola yo lo digo más que toda la partida directa ya no estará habiendo desde acá
pero eso ya es un poquito más para los que se dedican a este punto ya ya sé ya
tengo algunos errores y listo ya ahora si cuando hagan eso van a colocar
actualizar y se lo va a aparecer aquí lo que han subido ustedes y ahorita tengo problemas
con mi interno ya una vez que hagan eso bien acá a settings ahora hay dos dos maneros los
que hacen los ocho mandales es que les da sorbd y vamos bien acá donde dice uploading
un existen file vienen ahí ahí van a su carpetita todo esto lo jalan
lo jalan y lo que hagan con mi change
y ahí está su carpeta si no quieren hacerlo por consola ahí está tal cual ya está ahí
una vez que llegan ahí directamente vienen a mis settings y en settings
y ahí está zapatía zapatía zapatón voy a venir acá y voy a decir lo siguiente en este caso
hacen clic acá tempe de repositorio y aquí van a van a ver esa acá a la odis que algo dice peyes
hacen clic en peyes y van a colocar deploy si lo dejamos ahí aquí en normal van a colocar
main ya y van a colocar save
y ahora es vamos a esperarnos 30 40 segundos mientras todos les voy a explicar esta parte
que me dice acá miran van a ver lo que dice con una cuenta de interprice puedes
restringir el acceso a tu sitio de github pages publicando de forma privada puedes puedes usar
sitios privados para compartir tu documentación interna o bases de conocimientos con los miembros
de tu empresa puedes provide interprice por 30 días pero este aspecto que me dice a mí esto
es lo que me interesa de aquí puedo crear una cuenta con interprice si quieren pueden comprarse
para en vez de comprarse ponganles hosting u otras servidores con caritos pero antes de poner
la producción siempre es bueno que lo caló acá y hacer pruebas cómo funcionaría en línea
así que voy a actualizar ya me voy a aparecer ya me ha parecido esto es mi link
en la cual yo voy a poder entrar a mis proyectos ya ahí está ahí apareció
este en línea si les paso a ustedes deberían poder ingresar
porque esto ya funciona
en línea ya les enviado a ver ingresan y van a ver todo lo que yo estoy viendo pero desde su celular
desde su computadora desde donde quieran que quieran entrar ya pueden ingresar a mi empresa
ya entonces eso es lo que tienen que si o si ustedes
pero me están mensajando sus compañeros que me dicen
que se les ha cortado la
eso a ver ingresan llegan lo mismo ya ahí tiene que estar publicado sus proyectos
si es que para sus defences y demás pueden utilizar sus versel también los que son programadores
y eso no se puede pero netamente los que no yo les recomiendo esto o versel mañana que
el sábado bueno siguiente cuándo vamos a ver ser para hacer un diploy ahí no publicación y
colocarlo en línea ya la parte ahora entraremos a la parte más complicada no complicada si
nos hace un poquito tiene varios pasos ya ahí viene ahora pueden agregarlo aquí más por ejemplo
la siguiente mano os voy a indicar de esa parte no quiero complicar la vida pero ya avanzaremos
esta parte ya entonces ya están en su pavís supongo voy a irme a mi dashboard
ya su pavís les explico rápidamente que es su pavís es una base de datos netamente que es de
posgreso tiene bueno la base fundamental de su pavís es posgles y es una base de datos se secuela
la cual lo mismo que hemos trabajado en acá por ejemplo
lo mismo que hemos trabajado acá en maíes secuela
y lo voy a abrir con la arroja
ya lo mismo que han trabajado acá bueno ustedes han hecho como es que
así que esa parte no se lo siguiente
vamos a entrar acá y bien turn me
listo
y en cenar se acaso mis gracias de acá de ustedes era más maya secuela fron
así que no hay ni el mismo yo solamente trabajo en otro con otras cositas pero todo estaba
así datos estaba localmente en ustedes no ya ahora yo lo voy a hacer de manera online en la nube
y esto me acepto dos proyectos antes aceptaba casi cuatro cinco ahora no sé por qué ha bajado
bueno de las utiliza muchas personas también por eso a veces los reducen la cantidad de
proyectos máximo puede crear dos proyectos y en este caso dynamic aquí está ya ahora
como no sabía estaba haciendo la prueba con zapato hace rato para darles una para volar la clasa
pero voy a hacer con ustedes voy a borrar este solar no sé si lo necesito
de
van a ser tins para borrar es eso por si que se ves quizás se va a generar y aquí van a colocar
solar
y lo eliminamos
y esto digamos esto más que lo eliminarlo ven en acá abajo está del ed y van a copiarse de nuevo
el mismo nombre de su proyecto lo copian lo pegan y lo eliminan
listo
ahí va a estar listo ya está ahora les va a decir no hay que estar ustedes así no evito
con lo que no correct van a venir acá
ya digamos acá
voy a colocar
zapatero
ya van a colocar una contra señal que se acuerda
y lo crean
ya una vez que lo crean van a abrir un bloque de notas bloque de notas siempre es necesaria siempre
siempre siempre ya voy a abrir un bloque de notas
porque ellos no me guardan sus contra señal su usuario y demás en mi caso
y esta
ahí estaba de mí creo que esto de psique esto creo que no sé ni quieres esto de mi clave
credenciales ahora se va a irme acá
y voy a hacer lo siguiente
bueno acá copiamos este proyecto varl
que van a copiar
voy a colocar su pavéis
ya ahora vienen acá en la vida donde era aquí está viene por exit en prex settings valen
sea api key de api key se van a ir a legacy a non service rule y van a copiar este reveal no es
este hay veces tiene error es esto es un exclusivo reveal lo copian y se van a pegar en su
esto para mí la
listo ya eso se copian siempre guardense porque estar entrando nuevamente y todo lo demás
tedioso ya esto luego se van a hacer con el editor y vamos a codificar
ya voy a pedir la lla para que me la haga porque
para ganar tiempo pero no creo que la logremos hoy día ahora voy a irme a mi workflow
y acá dentro de acá voy a entrar acá voy a ir vamos a lo básico que ya hemos aprendido ya
hay perdón aquí está
listos luego de laretenplaying Texas y demás
cito ésta necesito
y c luego de in Waar
y ahora voy a crearme un vercancito, necesito un sub-base.
Ya sub-base vector tools, este van a elegirse, no el vector.
Listo.
Luego van a elegirse un gmail.
Ay perdón.
Y van a colocar el mesas.
Perdón, son mesas.
Listo.
Luego van a colocar...
Mayos y Coelho pueden hacerlo igual para que trabajes con dos bases de datos, pero todo bien.
Podemos utilizar un Monday.com.
Sí, vamos a utilizar un Monday.
Luego, a ver qué pas podemos meterle.
Hayas un MCP.
Vector stores, voy a irme acá.
Se va a trabajar con milvos, pero...
Todavía no creo que hay transacciones.
Vamos a irnos a...
Auxony Map, vamos a entrar.
Algo interesante, tenemos Action Networks Tools, sería o Adalope Tools.
Adalope es bueno, pero...
Hay some brains que podemos alejaremos.
Y en esto el node...
Es donde el package haya.
Vamos a tener que decodificar esta cosa.
Mientras tanto, rápidamente nos caracteramos y hoy no más voy a utilizar.
Para hacer transacciones bancarias.
En VK me sirve.
Pero a ver si da...
523, very fire, listo.
Si esto voy a tener que...
Y voy a tratar de enseñar a decodificar.
Listo, listo.
Hacemos doble clic acá.
En Superbase...
Vengo a Credential.
Voy a añadir uno nuevo.
En este caso, mi host ya saben que es el...
Si se van a su blog de notas...
Estas se van a copiar.
Ya, y al calompeca.
Serpios World Secret.
Van a ser igual. Lo mismo que hemos hecho aquí.
Y hasta...
Pienso que estoy viendo los días.
WinBlin.
Ya, ahora sí.
Si.
He visto su credencia y es accesible.
Ya está.
El hemos conectado a la base data.
Esto lo voy a hacer.
Y ahora trabajaremos en algunos punts.
Esta parte igual.
Tengo que...
Está funcionando.
Ahí te voy a detectar.
Y aquí está funcionando.
Ya está funcionando bien.
Listo.
Esta parte igual hay que linkear.
A ver.
Vamos a añadir acá.
Venimos acá.
Por si acaso siempre...
Taten de conectarse.
Ya.
Listo.
Ya, ahora voy a venir acá rápidamente.
A mi falta un webhook.
Ya.
Listo.
Yo quiero retroladar.
¿Qué más necesitamos?
Un webhook, pero más...
A ver, cuál podemos...
A ver, qué es lo que vamos a hacer.
WinMaker.
Webhook sería.
Mmmmm.
Ah, no.
No.
Mmmmm.
A ver.
¿Qué fue eso?
Trigger.
Power.
No podemos añadir.
Bueno, hay artos.
Los orchestraciones también son interesantes.
Pero luego lo vamos a hacer.
Lo haremos rápido aquí.
Mmmmm.
Zapatería.
Zapatería deают las
En cats.
Dienta.
De marca.
Dicle.
fte.
Y acá os aníe rápidamente.
MYPSolo recordito.
the name
C82.
Misto.
ME,
y por último necesito el mensaje
ya ha de la mensaje no nos tomamos para ganar tiempo
vamos a hacer una attribución, ejecutamos, no me interesa mucho
voy a ejecutar el nuevo, lo grabaremos una parte
voy a trabajar con el otro
listo, quiero saber que es zapato
listo, cerramos, lo vamos a colocar el pin de ira, cerramos y ya está
en el desfile lo mismo, ya sabemos por qué estoy volando para ganar tiempo
ejecutamos, listo, acá me hace ese model
aquí ya estamos conectados, voy a ir a matéquiste, listo me hace ese model
listo, voy a elegir un modelo, voy a elegirme para no consumir tanto el mini
luego voy a colocar tipo sistema, en este caso lo voy a dar en un prompt
ese prompt va a ser lo siguiente
él es un asistente, hay perdón, de vendas, de zapato
quiero que me des o quiero que respondas al cliente en base a ese contexto
listo, tenemos diferentes tipos de zapato a nivel mundial
desde marcas, desde marcas con Nike, Adidas
que se llaman los que son de ingenieros, ya me habido con
yo que es Bebo, no sé, ya entre otros
responde al correo
muy tónico, mediante HTML y CSS con estilos impresivos
además, además guarda los datos del cliente
en la base de datos, en la base de datos de su pavais
llamada grabar su...
siempre en este caso tratan de colocarle el...
lo que quieren grabar con mayúsculo y lo demos con minúsculo
mientras tanto, voy a venirme acá y vamos a traer chat
listo, voy a venir al chat y voy a generar una tabla
primeramente una tabla de SQL en base a...
a SQL de su pavais, de una tienda de zapatos
en las cuales estoy utilizando las variables
nombre completo
con correo y minúsculo
listo
ya me ha creado, listo, lo voy a copiar
voy a irme directamente a mi su pavais
bueno, tú lo gustas de mi su pavais
lo pego acá
que no te dice aquí, ese culo lo pego ahí
agarro todo esto, lo hago, lo voy a colocar
without ls ya, porque esto es netamente para
criptografía y autenticación
listo, ya lo ha creado, success, no rows of thrones
está bien, aquí venimos
y fíjense, ya se ha creado, ahorita se va a actualizar esta cosa
listo, ya se ha creado, correo y mensaje
ahora si vamos acá, proyecto overview
ahí está todo, ya, así que vamos a alta tabla
ahí los la parte de la tabla que se han creado
con sus ideas tiene, ideas tiene
ya vemos el table editor
ahora voy a hacer lo siguiente, si se ha conectado bien
debería de actualizarse con mi sistema
y voy a mis, de nuevo mi workflow
voy a hacer doble clic acá
ya, ahora fíjense acá
esta parte, van a colocar use cost, costumics, clima
y van a colocar search, está bien
los siguientes, por ejemplo, para un esquemático
público lo van a dejar rows, está bien
operation, create, create a new row
si enfíjense, vamos a hacer los datos
ahora si, a donde voy a hacer los datos
ahí tienen que elegir, fíjense, va a aparecer
la tabla que acabamos de crear, dice contactos
y si nos damos cuenta acá
llegue contactos, ya, así que no hay problema
vuelvo a mi, acá voy a hacer contactos
ahora dice define below, hc column
vamos a dejarlo por defecto
aquí van a colocar add fields, ellos vienen ahí
y van a hacer los siglos, van a seleccionar
en base a lo que tienen como, entra de dato
fill name or id, hacen clic, dice
no van a colocar siempre, el integer lo van a dejar
a iv, porque esto automáticamente se incrementa
no, esto nunca lo toquen, ya
estos datos, nombre completo, lojar
add field, de nuevo, correo, lojarlo
el nuevo, add field, seleccionamos
hc message, y lojarlo
podemos añadir uno más el otro
pero ese es el port de defecto, se va a crear, ya
y eso, ahora pueden ejecutar aquí mismo
para ver si está funcionando
listo, ya está, funciona
los cierran, ya está en verdad
ya está trabajando medio que mi, ya
propon en cada parcer que ya hace un parcer no hay lío
porque tiene que trabajar consultándole
cuando coloque este, luego acá
tenemos que colocar lo siguiente, no
un message, ustedes saben
así que esta parte lo voy a cerrar
voy a add field, voy a dejar aquí el correo
aquí voy a colocar bienvenido
a la empresa
y media lo tenemos, message va a ser el mensaje
que me está generando mi modelo
así que voy a colocar el text
y adoption, app en el attribution
y vamos a colocar, ya, listo ejecutamos
ya está
listo, ya funciona todo
ahora voy a irme a mi correo
no sé si, ya me olvido de decir, es el correo
no es el correo
no, esto no era
listo, voy a abrir el tarpa por acá
me voy a enviar, a ver
vamos a elegir correo
ya me he enviado, 1828
ahí está
bueno, me doblé unos errores porque hay que mejorar prompt
así que esa parte no se preocupen
pero, ahí está, y ahora debería de actualizarse
bueno, debería de actualizarse mi supabase
pero no le ejecuto todavía de manera directa
pero el veremos
voy a ver mi supabase
sable editor, voy a ver contactos
ahí tiene que actualizarse, ahí está
listo, y eso es su proyecto
lo bueno de esto, que ya podemos sacar
automáticamente los datos de los clientes y demás
ya, entonces han visto que no es complicado
si nos quería, podemos darle
un poquito más de nivel
y un poquito más complejo, añadir más agentes
añadir ya correos, añadir más cosas
a modo que todo vaya mejorando
y vaya más estético y vaya armando
cuál es su tarea
su tarea para el día sábado
es presentar
voy a llamar a 5 personas al azar
me van a mostrar su
lo que han creado en su git, y el que estoy corriendo
y me van a enviar, para que yo vaya viendo
puede mejorar lo mil veces a ustedes porque la IA ya lo hace todo
así que, yo lo he hecho solamente para muestros
luego tiene que crear su supabase
y para que la siguiente ya lo conecte
directamente al sistema
ya podemos manejar luego apis de
whatsapp
que automáticamente a mi whatsapp me generen los pdf
todo lo demás, ya eso sería
a los que acaban de entrar
vamos a lo siguiente, nos había comentado
que vamos a pasar una hora y media sino una hora
para que extendamos un poquito y compramos el horario
que está imponiendo la embajada
bueno, esto voy a dejar de grabar, de un ratito